And this is so unfortunate.
It makes me so sad is that these kids are going to be changing their minds in a
few years, I say five to 10 years. So we're what is this?
This is going to be August, 2020 when this comes out.
So give it five to 10 years. They're going to be so many kids who are saying,
why did my parents let me do this? Why did mental health,
why did medical professionals let me do this?
They are going to have issues from being on hormonal treatments from surgery.
I'm already seeing all of these young people,
these D transitioners and it really breaks my heart.
And no one is listening to them and no one is taking them seriously. And it's,
there are going to be tons of class action lawsuits.
The title, the end of gender. Yeah.
I thought it was kind of interesting because it's like, you're,
you're dealing with and unpacking all of these seriously complex issues
related to identity and gender and everything else,
but you're calling it the end of gender.
Do you think that what we're left with at the end of this
conversation, if we can truly have it honestly,
is that gender won't matter? Won't exist?
What do you mean by the end?
Yeah, let me clarify. Because when I announced this,
when I noticed the announced the book on social media,
people got upset at me because they thought I was saying that this is like the
very super woke, far left end of gender.
And that gender doesn't exist anymore,
or that gender is completely what you want it to be.
And it's based in self-identification and there was no tethering to biology or
objectivity, and that's not at all what I'm saying.
And I really want to emphasize I'm actually.
The complete.
Opposite of that.
I'm saying gender is very much biologically based and it is
the misinformation and denial of science and denial of biology and denial of
evolutionary psychology that is leading us to not have a proper understanding of
gender. And that's why I see it's demise.
Yeah. So, so paint the picture that turns some of this around,
besides just some people getting braver,
like the political part of this event. I mean, when you see at this point,
all of these, you know, the LGBT organizations, uh, that at this point,
I think are just basically using gay people to now push the gender stuff.
I mean, what,
what has to happen to them or are there non-profits that are fighting this from
a correct scientific perspective? Like what has to happen now? Really.
What I see happening,
and I actually have a line in the book where I say I'm appalled and I love,
I love the gay community and I have many gay men.
Who've reached out to me over the years, complete strangers who say to me,
thank you for saying what you did because I was one of these children.
I actually had one individual reach out to me.
Tell me around this around the time my first op-ed came out, he said,
I was thinking of transitioning and I read your op-ed and I decided to wait.
And I'm so glad I did. So there is a line in the book where I say,
I'm appalled that the number of gay men who are in support of transitioning
children, because this is leading to the extermination of gay kids.
And what I really think is going to happen.
And this is so unfortunate and it makes me so sad is that these kids are going
to be changing their minds in a few years, I say five to 10 years.
So we're what is this? This is going to be August, 2020 when this comes out.
So give it five to 10 years. They're going to be so many kids who are saying,
why did my parents let me do this? Why did mental health,
why did medical professionals let me do this?
They are going to have issues from being on hormonal treatments from surgery.
I'm already seeing all of these young people, these deep transitioners,
and it really breaks my heart.
And no one is listening to them and no one is taking them seriously. And it's,
there are going to be tons of class action lawsuits.
And I already see good clinicians in the field who are concerned because they
know it's coming and,
and they feel at a loss because we've been trying to raise attention and get
people to take us seriously, but they just call us transphobic.
Right? And by the way,
it's not just the personal issues and the medical issues and everything else.
There's going to be an insane amount of legal issues that pop up there.
I think there's going to be kids. You know, they'll,
there'll be young adults at the time that are going to start suing their
parents.
I think they're going to start suing the doctors and probably everybody else
involved. I'm sure there were lawyers looking at that right now.
There's got to be right.
And I would say to your audience too,
because I'm sure they have been following the, these issues as well,
pay attention to the people who are most loudly and proudly embracing this and
saying, this is great for the kids. Because when this time comes,
they're going to turn around and say, we had no idea this was going to happen.
And they're going to pretend that they had no idea when they are coming after
those of us who are speaking out about it.
I know it's a little weird to be ahead of the curve. Isn't it?
Cause you kind of feel like you're behind it sometimes as,
as the things start to come true.
I feel the odd thing. And when I was writing this book, I felt the whole time,
it was a very emotional process for me because it felt very much like those of
us who see it,
it's like we're able to see the future and we're just trying to scream as loud
as possible to get people to pay attention.
Uh don't I know it. I know it, uh, you just mentioned the deep,
the D transitioning part of this. Is there a lot of literature is there,
or a lot of research on that as far as how many people have done it,
are they happier after? Are they suicidal after? I mean,
what are the numbers look like on that?
There was one study in Sweden that looked at people who had
transitioned and then Tran changed the,
the marker on their legal documentation and then changed it back.
And they found that about 2% of people who had transitioned changed back.
But the thing is not everyone who transitions does it legally.
And also the data collected for that study. It finished around 2011.
I think it was. So that was before this huge influx we see of young people,
especially young women identifying as male. Um, and I've written quite a bit.
And in the book I talk about rapid onset gender dysphoria,
which is this phenomenon of young women who are very quickly identifying as
male, wanting to transition to male, taking testosterone, again,
getting double mastectomy, um, when they were very gender typical as children,
it's usually very out of the blue.
Usually they have other mental health issues like autism. For a lot of them,
they have sexual trauma. That's not being talked about.
And so we don't yet have the data for that.
We don't know what that's going to look like.
Although there is one County in the UK where hundreds of Dee
transitioners are coming out and saying, I'm I have autism I'm lesbian.
And why didn't people, why didn't, why didn't professionals, you know,
do what they should have done, which is ask me questions.
Yeah. I can't imagine discussing anything almost more controversial than that.
You couple this sort of rapid transition with autism,
and then you get people to try to talk about that. It's like, no, one's good.
You could see why the average, uh, researcher just would just be like,
no way I'm not doing this.
No. And it's difficult enough to get a study published.
You have to get funding for your, I mean, the book,
I talk about a number of situations where researchers have gotten approval and
they've gotten money to do their study and still they have to deal with all
these extra roadblocks that pop up where people coming after them and
threatening them. So at the end of the day, you know,
the science is taking a very unfortunate turn.
I think we're going to look back on this period with,
with a lot of horror and disappointment,
but I'm hoping that the,
the outcome is not going to be that terrible if we start speaking out about it.
Yeah.
Have they done real research on the social pressures related to all of this?
So like when you mentioned the rapid onset where suddenly a whole bunch of girls
that otherwise, like, it sort of appears out of nowhere in essence, um,
that could it be from a peer group and then they're really doing these things
that are just really just crazily extreme to fit in,
in essence.
Yeah. So this,
the one study that's been done in rapid onset gender dysphoria to date was
published in 2018 by Lisa Littman.
And she did the research did suggest that there's a peer contagion aspect to it
and that these girls.
So for 40% of the girls in the study who had come out as trans very quickly,
they had at least half of their group,
their friend group also identify as transgender,
which is 70 times the rate of what you would see in the general population in
terms of people who identify as transgender.
So that in itself should raise a red flag in most people's minds.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about academia,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our academia playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist they're all right over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.